uh okay this is now just uh
it's
it's sad
that it has gotten to this point
donald trump has suggested
that at times past it would have been
appropriate to put some hillary clinton
operatives to death
to death to kill them
um there is a uh supposed spying
operation
um there's a court filing that happened
last week which i'll mention briefly and
it almost like doesn't really matter
what the facts are but i'll mention
that last week it was alleged by special
counsel john durham that clinton
campaign lawyer michael sussman paid
tech companies and researchers to mine
internet data to establish an inference
and narrative tying trump to russia this
was reported by fox news and the right
became absolutely titillated by it trump
put out a statement
saying
the latest pleading from special counsel
robert durham provides indisputable
evidence that my campaign and presidency
were spied on by operatives paid by the
hillary clinton campaign in an effort to
develop a completely fabricated
connection to russia by the way even if
true that's not what the allegations
expose but okay
trump goes on to say
this is a scandal far greater in scope
and magnitude than watergate that's not
true and those who were involved in and
knew about this spying operation should
be subject to criminal prosecution in a
stronger period of time in our country
this crime would have been punishable by
death
in addition reparations should be paid
to those in our country who have been
damaged by this
i would say at what point do we have to
say this isn't funny anymore but the
thing is we said that the day after
trump was elected in 2016.
it's now even
more not funny
it's hard to even know what words to
apply to this are there no consequences
for threatening violence as long as
you're in a position of power and have
money
something is very very wrong here
something is wrong that we have so many
people that hear this and they say
trump's right
go on
the right-wing enclaves go on the
right-wing subreddits check out rumble
where where i'm now you know paying
attention now that we're putting our
content up there and people hear trump
say this and they say he's right
these people should be put to death
they've not been even charged with any
crime never mind convicted it's not even
clear they did anything illegal
uh but they're there it's not it's not
just that trump is saying they should be
put to death there's a contingent of the
country that says they should be killed
and uh something is also very wrong
that there are never any repercussions
for any of this stuff if you're in a
position of power of course
um absolutely incredible and the fear is
i mean listen you guys know what the
fear is right
no repercussions for any of these people
we already saw how effectively trump can
incite a riot
we already heard from trump at his
recent rallies we're going to have even
bigger protests if they charge me with
anything if these investigations lead we
will have the biggest protest
which is again trump alluding to his
supporters doing violence his supporters
seem ready to do more violence
and we should be scared
we should be scared and i try never to
be hyperbolic here
uh
but at this point
i'm very worried about what the next
eight and a half months leading up to
the midterms will look like and then
depending on what happens in the
midterms depending if republicans take
over
what is going to happen in the lead up
to the 2024 election very very scary
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door
ready to eat no cooking no cleaning
dishes saves you a lot of time you can
choose from over 50 hot and cold meal
options there's smoothies grain and
noodle bowls soups i'm a big soup guy
many of you know that i also really
liked the vegan meatballs with marinara
noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below